[Música]
y seguimos en directo américa jorge
hurtado ya nos acompaña en el estudio
jorge feliz año nuevo lunar del tigre de
agua es el el año de usted sabe cuál es
su animal en este calendario no ahogar
hasta todavía no averiguaron hay que
averiguar eso por eso vamos a hablar
entonces en mianmar porque arriba un año
de golpe entre sanciones internacionales
y una profunda crisis interna a jorge
así bueno los militares a cargo a y
enfrentan un aumento significativo de la
pobreza la salida también de varias
empresas internacionales y por supuesto
el boicot de sus propios habitantes con
el kobe 19 afectando las finanzas del
mundo la crisis humanitaria del
conflicto armado provocaron que en 2021
el producto interno bruto de mianmar
cayera al menos 18 por ciento incluso el
banco mundial ha dicho que la economía
de mi hermana está gravemente débil y es
un 30% más pequeña de lo que eras en el
kobe y sin el golpe de estado la onu
dijo que la pobreza puede duplicarse
este año hasta los 25 millones de
personas casi la mitad de la población
aunque el consejo de administración
estatal o sea los militares salvando
tienen una visión más optimista y
aseguran que el último año se han
aprobado inversiones extranjeras por
valor de 3.800 millones de dólares
empresas como la noruega telenor la
francesa total la japonesa kirin y el
estadounidense de chevron han salido o
anunciaron su salida del país en medio
de un deterioro de los derechos humanos
muchos ciudadanos como convocan
constantemente a boicot contra las
autoridades militares las acciones van
raúl desde no pagar la factura de luz
evitar comprar productos en empresas del
ejército e incluso no consumir la
cerveza de mi hermana jorge y vamos a
cambiar ahora información porque nin ya
se anunció la creación de su moneda
digital e impuestos en cripto moneda
jorge así es así lo confirmó la ministra
de finanzas durante la presentación de
los presupuestos generales del estado
para el próximo año fiscal indio el
banco de la reserva de la india emitirá
esta rápida digital durante el año
fiscal 2002 veintidós 2023 basado en la
tecnología block change con lo que
esperan un impulso a la economía digital
a diferencia de las cripto monedas que
no están respaldados por un activo
físico esta moneda digital seguirá las
regulaciones establecidas
el banco central y su valor equivaldrá
al de una rupia real el ejecutivo
también notificó de la entrada en
vigencia de un impuesto del 30 por
ciento a las transferencias de activos
digitales virtuales donde se enmarcan
las cripto divisas y las famosas ene efe
o toquen los fungibles esto sin duda es
un giro del discurso anti cripto monedas
que tenía la india que en 2019 incluso
habían propuesto un proyecto de ley para
prohibir las monedas digitales y
dictaban penas de cárcel de hasta 10
años por posesión uso o minado de cripto
monedas escuchamos a la ministra de
finanzas allí
fenomenal e incluyen transaction
se ha producido un aumento fenomenal de
las transacciones de activos digitales
virtuales la magnitud y la frecuencia de
estas transacciones han hecho imperativo
establecer un régimen fiscal específico
en consecuencia para la tributación de
los activos digitales virtuales propongo
que se establezca que toda renta
procedente de la transferencia de
cualquier activo digital virtual sea
grabada al tipo del 30% 30 por ciento
hoy venimos a hablar de nuestra región
porque el presidente ecuatoriano
guillermo lasso emprendió un viaje a
china cuéntenos a qué se debe que va a
hacer por hoy al presidente ecuatoriano
bueno raúl estaba buscando
principalmente alianzas comerciales y
tratar de renegociar una deuda que tiene
el presidente ecuatoriano aterrizó en
china con dos objetivos puntuales
conseguir un acuerdo de libre comercio y
la renegociación de la deuda bilateral
ecuador de vía china unos 4.600 millones
de dólares de los cuales 400 millones
son deuda concesional o sea a muy bajo
interés y muy largo plazo pero debe
renegociar el resto la deuda viene desde
la época de rafael correa que en su
distanciamiento ideológico con
washington y los multilaterales buscó
alianzas en beijing escuchemos que decir
el presidente el azul
en este en esta visita
trataremos temas
como el interés mutuo de iniciar
negociaciones de un tratado de libre
comercio entre china y ecuador
y a la vez también
plantearemos de nuestro lado el interés
de renegociar los términos de la deuda
que el ecuador tiene con los bancos
chinos
ahí está el presidente de ecuador jorge
le digo los indicadores bueno la bolsa
de hong kong está de vacaciones hoy por
el año nuevo lunar acción en las
acciones asiáticas avanzaron impulsadas
por las acciones tecnológicas de eeuu
principalmente en europa estas acciones
subieron el martes siguiendo el
sentimiento de riesgo global optimista
después de un enero bastante volátil y
que nos trae hoy jorge como cifra el día
es buena o mala chévere no es tan
secreta podría ser buena sobre todo para
los suscriptores de exp 8 millones de
suscriptores fuera de eeuu agregó biomax
en 2021 el servicio de streaming de
warner miriam se lanzará en 15 países
europeos incluidos polonia y portugal y
rumanía el 8 de marzo con lo que estará
disponible en 61 territorios de europa y
américa además de estar rompiendo con
esta serie por sentada euforia que se la
recomiendo si no lo ha visto pues ahí ya
tiene una recomendación para el fin de
semana gracias por toda la información
nosotros vamos ahora a ver nuestro
primer reportaje del día
[Música]